Oh
we have endless choice but we also are
hardwired in certain ways to make
certain choices so for example as we
learn from language through Noam
Chomsky's work kids are programmed to
learn language a two-year-old kid can
learn Chinese I could never learn
Chinese and I'm a reasonably smart
affable character who could apply myself
to I couldn't do it
it's not a my wiring any longer as
Chomsky showed there's a program for
learning language which is associated
with being a kid there are programs for
a whole series of things in us the kid
may learn Chinese the kid may learn
Arabic but he's going to learn something
and so the issue is what's in the in the
system and what's easy for us to learn
and it appears that some of the things
that we find easy to learn our tricky
like my group is better than your group
or I want to have access to as many
females or males as I can independent of
what the consequences are of that or a
series of other things but basically
this is a massive question and the
history of recent biological science
shows that we have really not well
handled the problem for example most
universities and colleges in North
America England rest of Europe are
divided into two science faculties if
you will
there's the Natural Sciences and then
there are the Social Sciences with the
heavy implication that social behavior
is not natural it's inescapable that
that would be the conclusion but in fact
social behavior is natural and we have
very very little synthetic
analysis of behavior from both the
evolutionary and the contemporary point
of view in many ways and that has become
I'm afraid highly politicized and
consequently generates a lot more heat
than light
well first of all location location
location is very important as we know
secondly people will have with you
something called in sociology a sort of
mating
it happens to be a cruel fact of high
school that the quarterback gets the
girl who's regarded as the prettiest its
regarded as a cruel fact of nature that
Catherine zeta-jones ends up with Mike
Douglas people make choices depending on
what they think they can get if you will
out of the reproductive system and so a
lot of people fail they don't have any
partner and there's a huge issue for
example in the african-american
community in America where so many of
the males are imprisoned if you'll have
20 may be male and 20 males and one just
one male is in prison than the 19 other
females have to really chop and change
to make a proper connection and it puts
pressure on everybody and so in that
particular community we see the the cost
and so we one remembers Terry McMillan's
book Waiting to Exhale so here we have a
indication of the fact that yesterday we
have a lot of free choice but it's
usually within a kind of marketplace of
humans if you will to be crass about it
and that continues to exist and so
you'll you have women who will decide
never to date some guy who doesn't have
X or Y characteristics who doesn't have
a professional in quotes job yeah there
was a study done of medical students
male and female in a university in New
York and the males were quite ruthless
in how they evaluated the females
they would they said for example about
one of them why is she studying to be a
doctor she's good-looking she should
just marry one and they had very very
rigorous statements that they made about
they would only go out with two of the
ten women who were in their class
because of physical attraction or
whatever their metric but it was real it
was harsh and that goes on all the time
it's the story of high school and it's
real and it's painful it happens and the
consequences are that individuals have
to sort of figure out how to present
themselves if you look at female reading
habits any magazine 612 ways to make
yourself look better for five cents on
the cover or two hundred things that
will please him or various ways of
trying to attract a male in a very
competitive environment and not just a
male a good one that's the problem
males have a different metric and the
problem is many males realize that they
can't really hack it they're just not
going to end up doing this very well in
terms of their fantasies or their dreams
or even their ambitions
I guess I would say that I will always
look for what is the most basic motive
in a situation that people are in and so
I will assume that if a man and a woman
for example are deeply interested in
each other sexually I would assume that
it's not because one is a Buddhist and
the other is a Catholic it's because
they're interested in each other
sexually given their reproductive state
their biology and the like so here's
where in my trade we talk about the law
of parsimony parsimony means you try to
find the least complicated explanation
for any behavior and so if I've had if I
have a hangover it would be parsimonious
of me to say well I shouldn't go and
apply for a job as a nuclear physicist
because I'm not going to be at my best
and that's just the law of parsimony and
that shades quickly off into biology